hello everyone and welcome to today's
presentation
part of the agilent cell analysis global
conference
i am jennifer woods of lab roots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
now let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we will answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the ask a question box located
on the far
left of your screen i now present
today's speakers
kristen bursack phd principal scientist
mimetis and kristin olsen ph.d imaging
specialist
field application scientist biotech
instruments
now a part of agilent for a complete
biography on our speakers please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen
doctors bursak and olsen you may now
begin your presentation
the title of our presentation is mimetus
and biotech instruments a toolbox to
dissect the vascular impact of covid19
this webinar is a collaborative
presentation by dr kristen bursack
a principal scientist for mimetus and dr
kristen olsen an imaging specialist and
field application scientist
for biotech instruments now a part of
agilent so first let's discuss a bit
more about the virus and the vessel
covid19 is an emerging zoonotic disease
that has resulted in the current
pandemic and ongoing global health
crisis
the first case is the disease originated
in wuhan city in the hubei province of
china in december 2019
and owing to its highly infectious
nature the disease has spread rapidly
around the globe
at the completion of this presentation
on july 12 2020 the world health
organization reported over 12 million
infections worldwide
of these 12 million infections over 3.16
million were in the united states
accounting for 25 percent of the global
infections at that time
of those 12 million global infections
over 500 000 resulted in death
with over 130 000 fatalities occurring
in the united states accounting for 24
percent of the global covet 19 related
deaths
as of today just over three months later
the number of global infections has
grown from 12 million to over 38 million
with over 7.7 million confirmed cases in
the united states
and globally covet 19 has been the cause
of over 1 million deaths
with just over 213 000 deaths occurring
in the u.s
owing to the severe impact of this
disease throughout the world and the
high percentage
of morbidity and mortality it is of the
utmost importance to understand the
pathological mechanism of this disease
the causative agent of covid19 is sars
coronavirus 2 or sars cov2
a positive sense single stranded rna
virus and a beta coronavirus in the
family coronavira day
sars cov2 is one of seven human
pathogenic coronaviruses
whereas four of these pathogenic
coronaviruses typically cause
mild cold like symptoms the remaining
three pathogenic viruses sars covi
mers kobe and now sars covi2 can cause
severe disease
with sars covi and mers kobe resulting
in epidemics in 2003 and 2012
respectively
during infection sars cov2 enters into
host cells by both receptor mediated
entry
and receptor independent plasma membrane
fusion
during receptor mediated entry the viral
spike glycoprotein binds the angiotensin
converting enzyme 2
or ace2 receptor that is expressed on a
wide range of host cells
while sars cov also binds the ace2
receptor to facilitate entry and cause
disease
sars cov2 binds at a much higher
affinity
this increased affinity may play a part
in the increased infectivity and
worldwide spread of this novel virus
additionally the expression of the ace2
receptor on a wide variety of cell types
in multiple organ systems
may facilitate the systemic spread of
the virus in moderate to severe disease
sars cov2 can be transmitted both
directly and indirectly from an infected
host to a non-infected individual
unlike many respiratory viruses sars
cov2 can be transmitted from an infected
host even if they are asymptomatic or
pre-symptomatic
making it very difficult to discern if
any individual is contagious
in direct transmission an infected host
transmits the virus to a non-infected
individual directly
in the case of sars kobe 2 this is
mainly mediated by respiratory
transmission of large
short-range respiratory droplets these
virus-containing droplets are generated
when an infected individual sneezes
coughs
laughs sings or even talks
if a non-infected person is within range
of these infectious droplets
they can be exposed to the virus via
inhalation depositing infectious virus
into the upper and lower respiratory
tract
or even exposure via the mucosal
membranes of the eyes nose or mouth
the risk of direct transmission of stars
cov2 can be greatly reduced by following
social distancing guidelines
and properly wearing masks when in
public
indirect transmission of the virus
occurs when the virus is transmitted
from the infected host
to a susceptible individual indirectly
for sars cov2
this can occur via suspended small
particle long-range aerosols
or contamination of inanimate objects
termed fomites
while there has been controversy over
the aerosol transmission of stars kobe 2
the world health organization and
centers for disease control have updated
their guidance
stating that in indoor spaces with poor
ventilation small
particle infectious aerosols may remain
suspended and pose a greater
transmission risk than previously
thought
in the case of stars cov2 fomite or
vehicle transmission
could occur from infectious droplets
contaminating surfaces
such as doorknobs office equipment or
even the card reader at the cash
register
if a susceptible individual touches that
surface and then touches the mucosal
membranes in their mouth nose or eyes
they could become infected with the
virus the easiest way to prevent this
type of transmission is to avoid
touching your face
and making sure that you're frequently
washing your hands with soap
while foamites may contribute to
transmission they are currently thought
of as playing only a minor role in the
spread of the virus
previous data suggested that additional
roots of stars cov2 indirect
transmission may occur from fecal
shedding of the virus
while the virus and viral rna have been
isolated from contaminated wastewater
this is currently not considered to be a
likely source of indirect print
now that we understand the origins of
this disease and how the virus can be
transmitted
we should discuss the clinical
characteristics of covet 19.
there has been great difficulty in
characterizing the clinical course of
covet 19 due to the spectrum of disease
and severity that occurs in different
individuals
some infected individuals may be
completely asymptomatic making it very
difficult to truly know how many people
have been or are infected in addition
many cases exhibit only mild symptoms
typical of other respiratory viruses
including a low-grade fever
cough fatigue sore throat body aches and
headache
these symptoms make the disease
clinically indistinct from other
respiratory infections
during the early stages of the pandemic
this may have also led to a reduction in
infected individuals reporting
or being tested for infection in some
individuals
mild cases progress to more serious
symptoms most commonly shortness of
breath or dyspnea
this shortness of breath can result in a
moderately severe pneumonia and may
require hospitalization
in severe cases respiratory symptoms may
progress to acute respiratory distress
syndrome or arts
or other severe disease complications
including but not limited to
acute kidney injury cardiac injury
septic shock metabolic acidosis
coagulation dysfunction
liver dysfunction and secondary
infection
in a percentage of individuals this
disease is fatal while a majority of
fatalities are associated with age or
underlying conditions we do not yet
fully understand the reason this disease
causes death in some individuals
while causing mild or no symptoms in
others
the disease course and timeline can vary
but in many individuals who will go on
to experience moderate to severe disease
the timeline is as follows incubation
during which an individual is
asymptomatic or pre-symptomatic
can last from 2-14 days during this time
the individual can transmit the
infection to others before knowing they
are infected
during the symptomatic phase an
individual may experience severe
symptoms such as dyspnea in the first
two to five days
typically these individuals will require
hospitalization within two days from
dyspnea onset
and if this progresses to arts the
individual may remain in the hospital
for 10 days or more
by 21 days post symptom onset symptoms
will begin to decline in many
individuals
and they will experience convalescence
of the disease by four weeks after the
onset
while the disease course is an example
many individuals can resolve sooner than
this
and some individuals will go on to
experience sequelae
and post-disease symptoms long after
convalescence has occurred
so what has made sars cov2 such a
successful pathogen
the success of any pathogen is defined
by the following characteristics
infectivity or the capacity of a
pathogen for horizontal transmission
from one individual to another
transmission or how the pathogen passes
from an infected individual to a
non-infected individual
and disease course the resulting
pathology of the disease
the spectrum of disease experienced by
infected individuals
and the tissue or cell types that are
infected
infectivity can be mathematically
defined by the number of individuals
infected by one infected host in the
current state of the population
a number referred to as the effective
reproductive number
when this number is less than one the
pathogen will not spread and when this
number is greater than one the pathogen
will spread rapidly
the current effective reproductive
number for stars cov2 both globally
and the united states is an average of
1.3 suggesting the pathogen will still
spread rapidly
factors that have contributed to the
infectivity of stars
include the availability of naive hosts
at the beginning of the pandemic there
was no pre-existing immunity to the
virus
and currently there are still many naive
and susceptible hosts available
additionally the virus has the ability
to evade the immune response on multiple
levels
lending to the inability of the immune
system to quickly control the infection
and prevent
further spread while pathogens are
transmitted via multiple mechanisms
sars kovi 2 is a respiratory pathogen
while we are still
understanding the transmission root of
the virus it has now been established
that it can be transmitted by both
short-range large respiratory droplets
in close proximity
and long-range fine particle aerosols in
enclosed spaces with poor ventilation
additionally the virus can be
transmitted by asymptomatic or
pre-symptomatic individuals making it
difficult to discern who may be
infectious
together these factors require that we
practice proper respiratory protection
and distancing at all times not just
around individuals that are displaying
symptoms
and finally the disease course of
covin-19 contributes to the success of
this virus
individuals can experience a very long
incubation period during which they may
be shedding virus before knowing they
are infected
this long incubation time may also delay
the individual from seeking testing
following exposure and make contact
tracing more difficult
individuals experience a spectrum of
disease making the clinical distinction
of covid19 difficult without appropriate
testing
and the tropism of the virus or the
types of cells that and tissues that the
virus can infect
is not limited to a single cell or
tissue type due to the distribution of
the ac2 receptor on many cell types and
tissues
the virus has the capacity to spread
systemically and infect multiple organ
systems
as mentioned there are many severe
complications of covid19
some of these complications are a direct
impact of the virus while others are the
result of an unchecked immune response
resulting in immunopathology
while covid19 is considered by many to
be a respiratory disease many organ
systems are impacted during infection
in most cases the lungs are the primary
side of infection and typically suffer
the most damage from the virus and
subsequent immune response
the virus typically will enter the body
through inhalation in the upper
respiratory tract
or mucosal membranes of the nose and
mouth then travel deeper into the lungs
into the lower respiratory tract
the virus impacts the airways inside of
gas exchange infecting bronchial
epithelial cells and alveolar epithelial
cells
during infection the virus can cause
cell death leading to a loss of
structure and damage to the delicate gas
exchange surface area
additionally infection and damage
recruits immune cell populations
causing the airway to fill with fluid
debris and inflammatory cells
the impacts to the cardiovascular system
are both direct and indirect
and will be the focus of the remainder
of this introduction
although typically considered a
respiratory disease recent data suggests
that covid19 may actually be a vascular
disease
the vascular pathology caused by stars
cov2 is a product of both the direct
and indirect impact of the virus shown
here as five different levels
with each level
leading to increased vasculopathy
endothelial cell death and subsequent
denuding of the endothelium
the loss in the endothelial cell barrier
allows fluid to leak into the
surrounding tissue as part of this
immediate impact
the indirect impact of stars cov2
infection on the vasculature is
demonstrated in levels two to five
the second level of vasculopathy occurs
during the massive inflammatory response
in moderate to severe
sars-cov2 infection the remaining levels
occur in patients with progression to
sequelae
associated with increased morbidity and
mortality in the third level the massive
inflammatory response and coagulation
response to damaged vessels
and resulting tissue damage can lead to
tissue ischemia and hypoxia
this decreased oxygen can trigger an
increase in angiogenesis or the
formation of new blood vessels in the
affected tissue
in advanced cases of covid19 this
process is dysregulated
leading to deformation of the
vasculature and a loss of vascular
hierarchy
as the disease progresses and vascular
damage and leakage occur the coagulation
cascade is upregulated
causing the formation of microthonby and
thrombi in blood vessels and tissues
further amplifying ischemia tissue death
and contributing to hypoxia stroke or
pulmonary embolism
with the most severe pathology we see
the fifth level of vascular impact where
severe cases have marked angiopathy
where the vasculature itself is diseased
causing dysregulated circulation and
severe hemodynamic changes
that result from all of the
aforementioned impacts of the disease
now that we have discussed these
multiple levels of vascular impact
during star's cov2 infection
we'll provide a brief overview of normal
vasculature and pulmonary circulation
the endothelium is comprised of a single
layer of squamous endothelial cells that
line the interior of all blood vessels
and lymphatic vessels
these endothelial cells have three main
functions in maintaining homeostasis
they serve as a barrier between
circulating blood within the lumen of
the vessel and the surrounding tissues
through this function endothelial cells
communicate with neighboring cells to
regulate blood flow
and maintain hemostasis the endothelial
cells act in paracrine autocrine and
endocrine
ways to limit immune cell and platelet
interactions
and additionally the endothelial cell
tight junctions as shown in the
fluorescent microscopy image below
the endothelial the endothelium
functions as a gatekeeper
regulating leukocyte trafficking and the
access of plasma proteins to the
surrounding tissues
the maintenance and regulation of the
pulmonary vasculature is of utmost
importance
as the lungs and more specifically the
alveoli are the site of all gas exchange
in the body
the pulmonary circuit is responsible for
the oxygenation of all blood in the
systemic circulation
by transporting blood between the heart
and the lungs
following systemic circulation the
deoxygenated blood returns to the heart
and exits the right ventricle into the
pulmonary arteries flowing into both
lungs
in the pulmonary circuit there is a
defined vascular hierarchy with the
branches of the pulmonary artery
splitting and following alongside the
bronchial tree toward the alveoli
where each alveolus is surrounded by a
vast capillary network
the alveoli are terminal sacs of the
individual bronchioles providing a thin
but vast surface area for the vital
function of gas exchange
the alveolar wall is comprised of a
single layer of simple squamous
epithelial cells
the type 1 and type 2 pneumocytes type 2
pneumocytes are responsible for the
production of surfactant a fluid that
maintains surface tension within the
lung
when damaged or lost the type 1
pneumocytes can differentiate into new
type 2 pneumocytes maintaining the
production of surfactant
and preventing alveolar collapse beneath
this epithelial surface lies a basement
membrane
comprised of extracellular matrix a thin
interstitial space
and then the endothelial cell wall of
the alveolar capillary
these layers together are termed the
alveolar membrane and are the site of
gas exchange within the body
as the alveolar wall is comprised of
only a single cell layer
the alveoli are easily damaged loss of
alveolar type 2 pneumocytes can impair
surfactant production
causing decreased surface tension and
alveolar collapse as discussed above
disruption of the alveolar wall barrier
can also allow fluid to enter the
alveolar space additionally decreasing
the gas exchange surface area for the
remainder of this talk we will focus on
the first three levels of vascular
impact during sars cov2 infection
the direct impact of sars cov2 to the
endothelium occurs when the virus
directly infects endothelial cells
endothelial cells in the alveolar tissue
and more specifically the capillary
endothelium do express
the ac2 receptor as shown by
immunohistochemistry
suggesting that these cells are
permissive and susceptible to sars cov2
infection
additionally as2 is expressed on
endothelium of the brain and in vitro by
huvec cells
the primary human umbilical vein
endothelial cell line
mrna for tmprs2 the surface protease
that facilitates stars cov2 entry into
host cells
is also detected in qvex cells and
endothelial cells of the respiratory and
digestive tract
sars kobe 2 in vivo infection of
endothelial cells has been demonstrated
by immunohistochemical staining for sars
kobe 2 spike protein
revealing granular cytoplasmic
distribution in endothelial cells
derived from patient tissue sections
transmission electron micrographs of
skin and lung sections from covid19
patients also display
virus-like particles inside endothelial
cells in both tissue types
the indirect vascular impact of the
sars-cov2 infection begins with the
innate immune response
the innate immune response in the
alveolar space is initiated by the
intracellular cytoplasmic sensor sensors
signaling the detection of
pathogen-associated molecular patterns
associated with viral infection and
replication
this initial response produces hemokine
signals from the resident alveolar cells
that recruit innate immune cells such as
neutrophils and inflammatory macrophages
to the site of infection
as these cells move along hemokine
gradients towards the endothelium
they'll upregulate factors involved in
rolling in adherence slowing their
movement as they approach the site of
infection
at the site immune cells will
transmigrate through the endothelial
barrier
and into the infected tissue when there
is an abundance of immune cells
trans-migrating into the site the
barrier function of the endothelial
cells can be compromised or damaged
leading to vascular leakage into the
interstitial space or even into the
affected tissue site if the alveolar
barrier function also becomes
compromised
this leakage can cause pulmonary edema
to occur where fluid fills a portion of
the alveolar air space
the vascular leakage results in an
up-regulation of the coagulation cascade
and recruitment of platelets to restore
the barrier
at the same time the loss of alveolar
pneumocytes caused by either direct
infection from the virus or off-target
damage from recruited immune cells
can lead to a loss in surfactant
production and decrease surface tension
leading to alveolar collapse
once this occurs there's a partial loss
of gas exchange surface area
and unchecked will eventually lead to
tissue ischemia or overall hypoxia
as increasing portions of the lung are
damaged or become collapsed
this immunopathology cascade results
from a dysregulated
and abundant immune response to the
viral infection when this occurs the
patient experiences what is called acute
respiratory distress syndrome
a morbidity associated with moderate to
severe covid19
during this process the virus can easily
move from the site of infection the
alveolar space
into the vasculature where it can infect
ace2 expressing endothelial cells and
move into systemic circulation
spreading the infection to other organ
systems with vascular leakage activating
the coagulation cascade
microthrombi are deposited into the
vasculature to restore homeostasis
the dysregulated clotting and increased
recruitment of inflammatory cells
leads to blockage of small blood vessels
in the tissue this blockage prevents
oxygenated blood from reaching those
tissue sites leading to ischemia and
increased cell and tissue death
to compensate for this decreased
oxygenation and prevent further ischemia
from occurring
angiogenesis mechanisms are up regulated
producing new blood vessels increased
angiogenesis
is typically associated with sprouting
angiogenesis
that occurs during several
well-characterized stages including up
regulation of angiogenesis factors
and protease mediated escape of
endothelial cells from existing vessels
allowing those the formation of new
blood vessels from the existing vessels
however in covid19 patients there is a
noted increase in
intussusceptive angiogenesis in the
lungs in contrast to sprouting
angiogenesis
anti-susceptive angiogenesis is a rapid
adaptation
of the existing vascular network it does
not require immediate
endothelial cell proliferation but
instead emerges due to a reorganization
of existing endothelial cells
and the invasion of endothelial
precursor cells
anticipative angiogenesis in cobit 19
lungs is associated with the deformation
of the vessel architecture
and a loss of the typical vessel
hierarchy
overall these initial direct and
indirect impacts of sars kobe 2
infection to the endothelium
suggest that we need to further our
understanding of the vascular impact of
cobit 19.
thank you kristin for the detailed
introduction and for
really nicely setting us up for the rest
of the presentation
so in this section i'd like to review
the
the gap in our current resources or in
vitrovasculature models
so to better understand direct and
indirect impacts
of sars cov2 on vasculature it's really
important to have a physiologically
relevant
in vitro model which can be applied
across multiple fields from
basic and applied research to
therapeutic
and vaccine development while lately
there
there's been a movement towards
physiologically relevant 3d cell culture
the majority of in vitro models are
traditionally 2d static cultures
now these cultures have many drawbacks
including the lack of profusion
which we know is important for
maintaining endothelial cell morphology
and barrier function another is the
presence of artificial membranes which
act to support the separation of an
endothelial cell layer from saying
apical and basal compartment
and these membranes typically have small
pores which can
interfere with the sensitivity of assays
as well as
compound transfer further
some commonly used platforms also suffer
from low
quality of imaging and make which makes
the evaluation of cell morphology and
and staining challenging
other drawbacks of current models
include being low
throughput having increased reagent
consumption due to the amount of media
and or cells that are required to
prepare the culture
and finally for many of the the more
complex in vitro systems
compatibility is often a challenge
especially those microfluidic systems
which tend to require
special lab equipment including pumps or
tubing
that really makes the adoption of that
new technology
unattractive
and so mimetis has developed a platform
that when paired with the biotech
automated imaging analysis will help to
sort of bridge the gap in our current
resources and
enable the use of a high throughput
physiologically relevant
in vitro vascular model
and that platform is the mimetus
organoplate
so it's similar to other 384 well plates
microtiter plates that you may have
worked with before
however the bottom of the plate is two
layers of microscope quality glass which
contains microfluidic channels
and using a pipette you can actually add
cells
extracellular matrix gel media
and sort of build your stratified
tissues layer by layer
in the microfluidic channels and within
one two lane organo plate you can create
up to 96
individual tissue chips so let's go
ahead and zoom in on one of those chips
a single chip is made up of four wells
in a row
that are connected by microfluidic
channels the first well is an
inlet where you can add your
extracellular matrix gel
which fills the channel the second and
fourth wells are the perfusion
inlets and outlets where media with
cells can be added
to fill that perfusion channel and the
third well
is the observation window where we can
use microscopy and imaging techniques
to capture each of the miniature tissues
so it's important to point out that
there's no physical barrier that
separates
the perfusion channel from the gel or
the ecm channel
instead what runs between the channels
is a short
ridge of plastic called a phase guide
and so this phase guide actually acts as
a capillary pressure barrier
and so you can sort of pipette in your
liquid ecm gel
and the capillary pressure barrier will
pin the liquid within the channel and it
won't be able to spill into that
adjacent perfusion channel
so once the gel solidifies we can
actually add our cells in media
to the perfusion channel and then those
cells will be in direct contact with the
gel
so in the next few slides i'm going to
share with you some screenshots from a
video
that will nicely bring together
everything i just described and give you
a better idea of how a scientist might
use the organoplate
so here's view from the top of the plate
where we have a scientist using a repeat
pipettor to fill the individual gel
channels with
extracellular matrix gel and cells
here is a view from the bottom of the
plate where you can see the scientist is
working
down the column to fill the gel channels
with the repeat pipe header
as the capillary forces carry the gel
through the channel
here we see a cross section of the
channels and you can see that the phase
guide
in between the two is preventing that
gel
and cells the red gel and cells from
entering the perfusion channel
you can kind of see that pinning effect
in this case there's cells embedded in
the gel
and they maintain an equal z
distribution
as the gel solidifies and once the gel
solidifies we can add media to the
perfusion channel using a multi-channel
repeat pipettor
capillary forces pull the media into the
channel
and here we have a cross-section view
the medium is then in direct
contact with the gel and the cells
and here's a view from the bottom of the
plate with both channels filled
and so during profusion the nutrients
within the media are able to diffuse
into the gel channel
and allow for you know nutrient and
waste exchange between the cells
present there
we can achieve perfusion in the
organoplate with a programmable rocker
called the organoflow
the perfusion inlet and outlet wells are
act as media reservoirs
and you can take the plate place it on
the rocker
in your incubator and the rocking motion
drives the fluid between the media
reservoirs
through your microfluidic channel and
this thereby
introduces fluid flow into your culture
the angle and the time intervals of
rocking can be modified to change the
flow rate to best mimic the flow rate of
your tissue of interest
and so in addition to embedding cells in
the gel we can also grow cells
against the gel which often times when
cells are seated there in the perfusion
channel against the gel
they will form a tubule-like structure
mimicking
a 3d structure like a blood vessel
and the next few slides are screen shots
from the video
showing how to build a tubule structure
in the organoplate
so here we're viewing the bottom of the
plate and we typically start by adding
gel to the gel channel and allowing it
to solidify
there
following which we can add cells in
medium to the perfusion channel
here we have a view from the bottom
[Music]
now we're back to a cross section view
where you can see the cells in the
medium
on the left in the blue medium in that
perfusion channel
against our solidified red gel
now we're back to the bottom view and we
can see the the red ecm
on the top and the cells in the blue
medium on the bottom
and after you add your cells in the
medium
this is when you can actually flip and
invert your plate to allow the cells to
attach to that ecm
and once attached we can begin perfusion
and the cells will
begin to grow and form a tubule
structure within that perfusion channel
and here we have a 3d reconstruction of
a kidney tubule
which has been stained and imaged and in
the cross section you can actually see
that there's a lumen formed within that
tubule structure
within the perfusion channel with the
phase guide between the tubule and the
ecm
gel
so there's a variety of endothelial cell
models that can be built in the
organoplate
and the simplest model is growing an
endothelial cell tubule against
our ecm gel in the lane organo plate
where you can have up to 96 replicates
if you're interested in a more complex
model the three lane organa plate
is available where we have nine wells
that connect in a square
to make a single tissue chip and so this
totals 40 chips on a single 384 well
plate
and in that three-lane organoplate not
only can you
culture an endothelial cell tubule
against the ecm
to mimic a blood vessel but we can also
model angiogenesis
by inducing sprout formation from that
parent blood vessel
in this case you would first add
endothelial cell tubule to the top
perfusion channel
following which you can add angiogenic
cocktail of small molecules
in medium to the bottom perfusion
channel and a gradient of factors
is then formed in the culture and this
allows for the formation
of angiogenic sprouts from that parent
vessel through the ecm
another organoplate type which enables
3d vascular cultures
is the organoplate graft with six wells
connecting to make a single tissue chip
and a total of 64 chips per plate
similar to the three-lane organoplate
you can add an ecm gel to that middle
channel
and endothelial cells to the side
perfusion channels to form blood vessels
however the graft is a bit unique in
that the middle
ecm channel is actually open on the top
so that it allows you to place a piece
of tissue
say a spheroid or an organoid and
ultimately be able to vascularize that
tissue
so here we have a cartoon of how to
build organoplate graft cultures
with the top down and cross section
views provided
so we start off by adding your
endothelial cells against the ecm
and allow the cultures to perfuse for a
few days and to form the blood vessels
in those perfusion channels
then we can add the angiogenic sprouting
medium
to that middle graft chamber on top of
the ecm
and induce angiogenesis and once that
vascular bed is formed we're able to
place a piece of tissue or spheroid
on top of that vascular bed and
ultimately with more time
that piece of tissue itself becomes
vascularized as
kristen just spoke about the mometus
products offer the ability
for quick and easy analysis of your
vasculature
formation via microscopy
and imaging biotech automated microscopy
instrumentation
offers modular and upgradable systems
designed to suit the needs of the user
and provide automated imaging and
analysis
there are two lines of automated imaging
instruments
the citation cell imaging multi-mode
readers and the lionheart automated
microscopes
while the lines offer different options
and configurations
all biotech imaging instruments are true
microscopes
providing a variety of imaging
applications and compatibility with a
range of supported
wear including slides dishes chamber
slides cell culture flasks and low
density and high density microplate
formats
additionally all instruments provide
onboard temperature control
4-channel imaging with bright field and
fluorescent imaging standard across
all instruments configuration dependent
options include color bright field face
contrast and high contrast bright field
imaging modes
additionally biotech offers a range of
imaging accessories
providing the user with the ideal
configuration for their applications
these include over 22 fluorescent filter
cubes and color matched leds
ranging from uv to near infrared and
olympus and zeiss objectives
the citation cell imaging multi-mode
readers offers a unique design
providing configurations that allow
automated microscopy and conventional
microplate detection in one modular and
upgradable platform
for imaging the citation systems offer
onboard capacity for up to six
objectives
with compatible magnification from 1.25
x to 60x air
for workflow automation the citation
instruments are compatible with biotech
automation accessories
along with additional third-party
automation systems
for lifestyle workflows the gas control
module can provide both carbon dioxide
and oxygen control
and the optional dual reagent injector
module provides automated injection of
up to two
compounds integrating injection with
imaging or detection analysis
in contrast the lionheart automated
microscopes provide a compact and ocular
free design
and offer a wide range of imaging
capabilities in a modular and upgradable
platform
the lionheart systems provide onboard
capacity for six objectives
with compatible objectives ranging from
1.25x up to 100x oil
the lionheart fx is ideal for live cell
imaging with optional co2 and o2
control and humidity chambers available
for rapid kinetic assays the lionheart
fx is compatible with the dual reagent
injector module
biotech automated microscopes produce
high quality images full of rich
phenotypic data to move your
applications forward
image capture options include endpoint
or kinetic capture
capturing a single image choosing
capture beacons or montaging across a
large area
capturing a single focal plane or
imaging 3d biology with z-stack imaging
depending upon the instrument
configuration images can be captured in
fluorescence bright field
color bright field phase contrast or
high contrast bright field
together with biotech's automated
imaging instrumentation and hardware
the gen 5 imaging and analysis software
creates the unique
augmented microscopy experience
augmented microscopy is the integration
and automation of all steps from image
capture
the processing and analysis in the gen 5
software eliminating the need for post
processing
post analysis or additional software and
providing publication ready data
with augmented microscopy the imaging
workflow is fully automated to increase
throughput while providing both
qualitative and quantitative data
in this example workflow the researcher
has transfected cultured fibroblasts
with a vector expressing gfp
the end goal of this assay is to use
imaging to determine transfection
efficiency
during the capture step they are
capturing a single image in the center
of the well as described in their
protocol
to optimize their image for downstream
analysis in processing they add a
background flattening step
to analyze their images for transfection
efficiency
the researcher uses the gen 5 dual
masking technique
and applies a primary mask onto the
dappy signal
this primary mask will provide a total
cell count based on the dappy signal
but also identify each nuclear signal as
an individual object or event
from there they are applying a secondary
mask to the cytoplasmic compartment
allowing the researcher to
determine the total gfp signal within
the cell
once the primary and secondary masks
have been defined
the researcher can decide how they want
to define their subpopulation of
gfp-positive transfected fibroblasts
based on a variety of object-level
metrics and control images
here they have defined their cells as
gfp-positive using a mean gfp intensity
threshold in the total cytoplasmic
compartment
once defined cells in the subpopulation
can be visualized on an image level and
by scatter plots and histograms
to normalize their data the percentage
of gfp positive cells can be calculated
by adding the ratio calculation in our
post analysis options
this augmented microscopy protocol is
applied to the full plate of cells
providing data output for any chosen
populations and metrics that can be
easily exported into excel
while this protocol is the best choice
for their assay there are a variety of
capabilities in the gen 5 software as we
have discussed
these include the additional capture
modes and additional capture methods
additional processing methods that
include deconvolution digital phase
contrast
image stitching or z projections for 3d
biology
and kinetic frame alignment for kinetic
captures the gen 5 dual masking
technique allows for many options in
image analysis
allowing distinct analysis of signal
between nuclear and cytoplasmic
compartments
thresholding custom object level metrics
and displaying data in both histograms
and scatter plots
additional data reduction tools for post
analysis methods
include ratios deltas normalization
custom equations
and methods for qualitative analysis and
quality control
now we're going to jump into how to use
imaging to monitor the growth
and morphology of your tubular and
vascular bed
endothelial cultures in the mimetus
organoplate
here we used a two-lane organoplate
to grow immortalized endothelial cells
called h-mech ones
against a gel and over time you can
track
the culture morphology easily using
phase contrast imaging
and we captured these images using the
biotech
citation five you can see on day zero
when the cells are added to the
perfusion channel that they have not yet
adhered to the ecm
or to the channel and so after the cells
have finally attached
over time you see a nice progression
from days one through day eight
of the endothelial cells forming a
healthy confluent monolayer
you can also use bright field imaging
with the citation 5
to monitor the culture morphology and
here we
have a vascular bed of huvex in the
organoplate graft
and we can see the progression and
growth of the vascular sprouts
towards the middle graft chamber over
time
using the mometus products the
organoplate and organoplate graft to
produce endothelial cell tubes and
vascular beds
we can better understand the interaction
of stars cov2 and the endothelium in a
biologically relevant model
in the following sections we will walk
through a variety of virology specific
applications and examples made possible
by the combination
of mometis technology and biotech
automated microscopy and instrumentation
using these models let's first
investigate the direct impact of stars
cov2 on the endothelium
prior to infecting cells it's important
to determine if a host cell type is
permissive and susceptible to viral
infection
for any viral infection permissivity and
susceptibility will require the presence
of the receptor
allowing the virus to enter the cell
using qpcr we confirm the presence of
both ace2
and tmprss2 transcript in the
endothelial cell tubes grown in the 2d
organoplate and the vascular bed growth
in the organoplate graft
suggesting these cells will be
permissive to sars cov2 infection
to confirm the susceptibility of
endothelial tubes to the virus and
determine viral infectivity
endothelial cell tube cultures were
infected with a fluorescent reporter
strain of the virus
and incubated to allow infection to
progress
prior to imaging a live cell nuclear dye
was added to allow quantification of
total endothelial cells
and normalization of infection using the
biotech citation 5 we developed an
imaging protocol to capture the full
endothelial tube in situ
as a montage z-step with augmented
microscopy
captured images were processed and
analyzed for the total cell count
gfp positive cell count and the
percentage of the gfp positive
subpopulation
in the absence of immunostaining
reagents or a reporter strain of the
virus many viral infections can be
detected by observing a notable
phenotypic change to infected cells
term the cytopathic effect or cpe
cpe is typically seen as either
cytotoxicity the rounding of infected
cells and subsequent loss of attachment
or sensation formation where the
infected cells fuse together
cpe can be used as an indicator for
infection in the absence of
virus-specific reagents
or as a screening tool the presence or
absence of cpe is typically indicated as
a binary plus or minus score when
screening wells
in this example we analyze non-infected
and infected endothelial cell tubes for
the presence of cpe
for this virus cpe is indicated by
cytotoxicity and a loss of cellular
attachment and confluency
to provide automated analysis for cpe we
determine the sum area of total
endothelial cells present in
non-infected and infected tubes
and this sum area was normalized to the
sum area of the non-infected tubes
providing a normalized percent
confluency output
based on a confluency threshold that we
determined we converted this percent
confluency to a binary cpe score
where confluency less than 75 percent
indicated the presence of cpe
and thus the presence of virus and was
scored a one
whereas non-infected tubes were scored
as zero
so using the organoplate three lane we
can also evaluate
barrier function and in this case you
can grow your endothelial vessel in the
top
profusion channel and once that barrier
has formed
you can add a fluorescent dye following
which
if all the tight junctions are
functioning and intact
then that dye will remain in that top
perfusion channel and will not appear in
the gel channel
however should the tubule have a
compromised barrier function
say due to cytokines or toxic compound
then you would expect that the
fluorescence would leak into that gel
compartment
and here we have an example below using
155 kilodaltons
bitsy dextran which were captured using
the biotech citation 1. we always use
a no cell control to understand how the
fluorescent dye
moves through the ecm without any cells
present
and that's exactly what we see here
next to that is an example of a leak
tight tubule
where our endothelial cells are forming
a complete barrier
and preventing the dye from entering the
gel channel
and finally there's an example of a
leaking tube where you can see some of
that fluorescence
is making its way into the gel channel
and we can measure this over time and
typically we can graph these data
by dividing the fluorescence intensity
inside the gel compartment by the
fluorescence
intensity inside the perfusion channel
and a leak tight tubule will maintain
low values over time
while a leaky tubule will sort of
increase over time towards a value
of one
so in addition to measuring barrier
function
a direct result of endothelial cell type
junction
function we can also evaluate the
expression of endothelial markers by
immunofluorescence
so we can fix and stain your cultures
directly in the organoplate
and here we can see robust the kid
hearing in green
and von willebrand factor in red in our
huvec
tubule now that we have discussed the
basic applications to study the direct
impact of the virus within the
endothelium let's move on to the
indirect vascular effects of sars cov2
infection
in this section we'll review how immune
cells interact with the endothelium and
some sample applications to study this
interaction
as we discussed earlier in this talk
immune cells are recruited to the sites
of infection and damage via cytokine
signaling and chemical ingredients
for this example we will focus on the
recruitment of neutrophils the body's
first responders
in this illustration the virus has
infected the alveolar macrophage the
resident macrophage of the lung
the presence of virus in the cytoplasm
of the cell and the replication
byproducts trigger cytoplasmic
sensing mechanism leading to the
production of pro-inflammatory cytokines
and chemokines
there is a gradient of chemokine
concentration with the highest
concentrations proximal to the infected
cell and decreasing with distance the
circulating neutrophils follow the
chemokine gradient from the systemic
circulation
and toward the alveolar capillary
network as the chemokine concentration
increases the neutrophils upregulate
their cellular
adhesion molecules and move from the
free-flowing lumen towards the periphery
at the endothelium surface the
neutrophils begin to roll along the
chemokine gradient
and then adhere to the endothelial cells
they will then
transmigrate through the endothelium and
through the alveolar epithelium as well
accessing the alveolar space once they
have accessed the site of infection the
neutrophils can release their
inflammatory byproducts and set to work
eradicating the virus
under typical conditions the
virus-infected cell is destroyed and
additional immune cells are recruited to
resolve inflammation and damage
the memetos organoplate can be used to
assay for immune cell adherence to
endothelial cells and better understand
the role of various inflammatory signals
in this process
mimetus has confirmed the ability to
model this immune cell adherence
in the organoplate as here they grew
human coronary artery endothelial cells
in the perfusion channel
once confluent they treated the cultures
with increasing concentrations of tnf
alpha for 4 or 16 hours
after tnf-alpha incubation calcine am
stained monocytes
shown in green were added to the
endothelial tube
with nuclei shown in blue for 15 minutes
following with washed and remaining
green monocytes were considered to be
adhered to the endothelium
tnf alpha promoted the adherence of the
monocytes at 4 and 16 hours at various
concentrations
as many inflammatory cell byproducts can
cause off-target damage to surrounding
cells and tissues
it's necessary to be able to assay for
cell death in this model
here endothelial cell tubes either
non-infected infected or control treated
were stained with hosh and propidium
iodide
the tubes were automatically imaged
using our gen 5 imaging protocol as
previously described followed by
cellular analysis
cell death was determined by propidium
iodide staining and quantified as the
total
propidium iodide positive cells the
percent of propidium iodide positive
cells
and the percent of endothelial cell tube
can fluency
as shown the infected cells exhibited
perpedium iodide staining and increased
cell death
while tubes treated with the positive
control exhibited an even higher level
of pi staining along with a more severe
loss of confluency
now we'll move on to how the memetis and
biotech platforms can be used to
investigate
vascular impact level 3 by modeling
changes in angiogenesis
so here we've added huvex to that top
perfusion channel
and once the tubule has formed
angiogenic factors were
added to the bottom perfusion channels
to promote
sprout formation and growth through that
gel channel
cultures were treated with increasing
concentration of that angiogenic
cocktail
sprouting mix and you can see a
dose-dependent formation
of the sprouts in the ecm and we capture
these images
using the biotech citation 5 and what's
really great about the instrument
and the gen 5 software
is our ability to quantify those
vascular sprouts
so using a cell mask gen 5 is able to
calculate the area
and the confluency of the sprouts which
is fantastic
while we have not yet evaluated the
contribution of
sars cov2 or hypoxia to angiogenesis in
the organoplate
this assay and data analysis package
would enable such
studies in addition to altering the
concentration of angiogenic cocktail
we can also observe a time dependent
formation of those angiogenic sprouts
in the organoplate graft and here you
can see the vascular bed is forming over
time
and a tissue explant is added following
which that tissue becomes vascularized
in conclusion sars kovi 2 the causative
agent of covid19
has resulted in an ongoing pandemic and
global health crisis
while we are still learning about the
pathogenic mechanisms of the virus and
the resulting disease
multiple characteristics of stars kobe 2
have contributed to this rapid spread
and morbidity and mortality associated
with disease
though covid19 has been considered a
respiratory disease
in moderate to severe patients multiple
organ systems are
affected indicative of systemic spread
systemic infection is associated with
severe sequela
and increased morbidity and mortality
current research suggests that coven 19
may actually be a vascular disease
where viral infection of pulmonary
endothelial cells can lead to a direct
and indirect effect of the virus on the
pulmonary and systemic circulation
this new direction allows researchers to
expand their focus outside of the
respiratory
system they explore additional
preventatives and therapeutics aimed at
preventing vascular infection
and subsequent damage and dysregulation
the goal of this presentation was to
provide researchers with a toolbox to
better understand this virus host
interaction
in a high throughput and automated
fashion
from the technology side for mimetics
i'd like to conclude
with just a few take-home messages the
first
that the organoplate vasculature models
address
many of the drawbacks of other in vitro
models
next is that there are many assays
available to evaluate endothelial cell
phenotype
and function and finally
i think we showed nicely in this
presentation that the organo plate is
quite compatible with the biotech
automated imaging platforms biotech
automated imaging and microscopy
instruments are available in a variety
of modular and upgradable platforms to
meet the needs of your specific research
with gen 5 imaging software and the
process of augmented microscopy
imaging protocols can be fully automated
for capturing processing and analyzing
your data
efficiently increasing throughput and
efficacy together with these mimetic
products and organoplate formats we hope
to offer research and
researchers a complete toolbox to better
understand the vascular impact of sars
kobe 2 infection
as always the medicine biotech
instruments are here to support our
customers during this time
and offer solutions to help in your
research efforts
and to accelerate your work we thank you
all for your attention
and we're happy to answer any questions
you may have
thank yous uh thank you dr zburzak and
olsen for your informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
let's get started our first question
is for cytopathic effect
you looked at a loss of confluency as an
indicator of cpe
can you also quantify cell rounding on a
cell by cell basis
yeah so that's a really great question
in addition to being able to look at
that cpe
indicator by a loss of confluency we can
apply a variety of metrics to detect
cytopathic effect
in your infected cells depending on what
that phenotype is
so that includes things like cell
rounding or sensation formation or even
darkening of the cells
as they start to lose attachment that
allows a nice focal detection of viral
infection early on also
okay awesome thank you our next question
did you evaluate automated liquid
handler to pipette in organoplate and
especially
the agilent bravo
that's a great question and i can feel
this one kristin
so here at mimetis we've actually worked
together
with an academic partner to use the
agilent bravo and successfully loaded
cells both in a gel
as well as against the gel um loading
nearly i would say almost 100 percent
success rate
and so in addition to to loading the
cultures we can actually use the agilent
bravo to
change the culture media add assay
reagents and things like that so it's a
really nice option
to kind of pair all three of the
platforms even
okay thank you we've got another
question here from the audience
um they say it's a really interesting
presentation and have you used biotech
imaging for herpes virus research
yeah so um i'm not sure if we've
directly used it for herpes virus
research but we have
worked with researchers with a variety
of viral infections
and i'd be more than happy to discuss
this kind of one-on-one during the
networking lounge
and go over some of the assays and
applications that you might want to
perform with the biotech imaging
okay and another question here acute
kidney injury is a morbidity
uh associated with covid could we use
these um momentous vessels to also grow
kidney tubules
in fact you can um so similar to the
the way you would have seeded
endothelial tubules you can sort of seed
your
your you know proximal tubule cells into
that perfusion channel and
after they undergo perfusion they'll
form a 3d
proximal tubule-like structure within
the perfusion channel
so definitely feasible okay
another question from the audience what
percentage of non-infected cells
cells and forming leaky tubules
so that's a good question so cells that
are not infected or
not impacted by toxic insult should form
completely leak-type barrier so that's a
hundred percent of the cells that are
not infected
form we type barriers and it's not until
we see that insult do we see any leaking
[Music]
got a couple more questions chris
kristen mentioned that she used both
citation one and the citation five what
is the difference between the two
instruments and is one better than the
other for organoplate imaging
i'll field that one so um the difference
is between the citation one the citation
five so both will work for your imaging
and the organo plate
um they're just slightly different
configurations so the citation one is an
affordable
option for um automated imaging and also
multi-mode microplate detection
there's a limitation in the number of
objectives that it can hold compared to
the citation five so it can hold two
objectives
the citation five can hold six um and
there's some additional limitations in
the
the types of imaging modes so with the
citation 5 you have the full range of
configuration options
and the best way to figure out which one
of those instruments would be great for
you is to just discuss it with a biotech
sales representative and a field
application scientist
and we will help guide you to the right
configuration based on your assays and
applications
okay great thank you so much we've got
another question
in addition to evaluating barrier
integrity is it feasible to measure
tier trans-endothelial electrical
resistance
within the organoplate platform
that's a good question um yes so we've
recently
developed a tier device you can actually
place these um
it's sort of like a plate lid that goes
on top of the lid and there's tiny
electrodes that go into each well
and all at the same time you can measure
the tier value for each of your cultures
and so this is extremely compatible
right now with our epithelial control
cultures and we're working towards
making it compatible with our
endothelial cultures and hope to have
that done by the end of the year
all right we've got one more question we
are hoping to analyze the impact of
infection on endothelial
endothelial cell type junctions how
would you analyze the loss of
tight junctions with microscopy yeah so
that's a great question and kristen
actually showed some data for this
but one of the best ways to do that with
endothelial cells is to stain for ve
cadherin
and then along with your nuclei and any
other cell markers that you'd like
and then we can look at the total ve cad
here in staining
through a variety of different metrics
so we can look at the confluency of that
staining the intensity and also
look at different ways of analyzing that
as it breaks down
so yes definitely something you can do
and immunostaining is going to be the
way to go
well thank you dr kristen bursack and dr
kristin olsen
for your time today and for your
important research
before we go i'd like to also thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed
by the speakers via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
through july of 2021.
until next time goodbye